these are the moments of magnitude 7.6
earthquake struck Western
Japan the ground shakes for nearly a
minute in the city of wajima near the
epicenter of ishika prefecture down
power lines sparked fires but across
Japan's western coast there was another
threat a major tsunami warning is in
effect for Noto Ishikawa prefecture we
are currently observing a large tsunami
people near the shoreline and Riverbanks
please evacuate to Higher
Ground nearly 13 years after a tsunami
and the most powerful earthquake ever
recorded in Japan killed more than
20,000 people here are scared and run to
hide the whole room was shaking the TV
was shaking I had to keep um everything
um on the table uh yeah uh I do I did
felt safe in my room
but everything else was
shaking the impact of the Quake leaves
homes in
Ruins roads fractured and debris
scattered across
streets that prompted concerns about the
safety of nearby nuclear power plants
played down by Japan's nuclear
[Music]
Watchdog there are currently no reported
irregularities with nuclear power
plants but a threat is not over
seismologists are warning of possible
aftershocks or another strong earthquake
and say they could happen at any moment
Axel zovich Al jaaz so let's take a
closer look at where the earthquake
struck now the epicenter of the 7.6
magnitude Quake was in the central
Ishikawa prefecture people living in
Western Japan were told to move to
Higher Ground or as far away as possible
from the coast now the Quake has
extensively damaged public
infrastructure roads in the city of
wajima have cracked and more than 36,000
homes in Ishikawa prefecture without
power Chris Gilbert has more from
Tokyo they're asking locals to stay
vigilant uh that is the message coming
from the Prime Minister because it does
seem as though uh high tide has passed
in uh that part of the country uh that
the tsunami um you know by all reports
warnings are not going to become more
severe in fact they have been downgraded
from a major tsunami uh warning to just
um you know a tsunami warning in the in
the last hour or so and so they're
asking um you know locals to not be
complacent yet um but that may be uh you
know just the tip of the iceberg in in
in terms of what people in the
government is facing uh the major issue
at the moment is the number of buildings
that have collapsed uh tens or dozens uh
depending on uh you know the reports
you're looking at uh the government has
identified at least 6 to 10
uh people trapped inside buildings and
maybe uh much higher than that
considering the government is usually
quite conservative about about these
numbers until they're official as you
can see it's also quite cold and this is
in Tokyo it's much colder on the Sea of
Japan side of the country and so even if
people aren't uh trapped in a house
that's collapsed they are trapped
necessarily in a house without any
Heating and there's a lot of older
people in that part of the country as
well as we heard in the report there's a
large fire in wajima the roads are
broken Services can't get through um and
so on top of the tsunami a whole lot of
uh Pils going on at the moment for the
people of
isikawa